era un viaje largo y peligroso al sur de
egipto para llegar a este lugar la única
forma era en grupo y escoltado por las
fuerzas armadas de este país obligatorio
no había opción es la única forma de
llegar después de tres largas horas de
camino de desierto inhóspito
prácticamente por la carretera por ambos
lados no había nada puro desierto
finalmente llegamos era nada más y nada
menos que en la zona arqueológica de abu
simbel
uno de los principales lugares y más
importantes dentro de la cultura egipcia
por fuera impresionantes esculturas
enormes que imponen la verdad y por
dentro ni se diga había dibujos
esculturas había pinturas había
jeroglíficos tanto en el piso como las
paredes como en el techo
inclusive tenían colores genuinos con
unos auriculares originales todavía yo
quería llevarme una imagen de lo que
estaba viendo pero era vaya reiterativo
por parte del gobierno que te decían que
no se podían las fotos era prohibido
inclusive te podían llegar a penalizar
si lo hacías dentro del templo lo que
ellos no sabían es que pues yo era
mexicano y como todo buen mexicano dije
bueno pues vamos a ver si no hay cámaras
no hay guías no hay oficiales no hay
policías
empecé a buscar y pues no vi nada le
dije bueno pues vamos a sacar la cámara
y muestra una fotito a cabo pues una es
ninguna y clic tomé una fotito un lugar
que me gustaba después dije mira que
padre salió otro ratito voy a otro lugar
muy padre y clic con otra foto del fib
al face clic otra foto no he dado cuenta
y allá va a ser de que como unas 200
fotos higiene pura mentira todo lo que
dijeron en la entrada porque será nomás
para asustar obviamente
déjame tomando fotos donde estaba
tomando otra foto de repente siento así
volteo y hole era un tipo como de unos
dos metros enorme pelón grandote así
super fornido tienen músculos tenía
músculos estén las uñas y en las
pestañas no sé cómo pero está lleno de
músculos del tipo
hagan de cuenta que era un hulk versión
tutankamón me dice dame tu cámara yo me
quedé helado obviamente se la tuvo que
dar
me dicen cuántas fotos tomaste le digo
poquitas
y me dice tú sabías y desde un principio
te dijimos tanto en señalamientos como
de manera oral que estaba prohibido las
fotos y vas a tener que ser sancionado
por ello híjole me dijo eso y la verdad
me quedé congelado empecé a empezar a
temblar empecé a sudar empecé a mi
corazón empezó a palpitar muy rápido a
palpitar muy fuerte yo sentía inclusive
mis propios latidos estaba muy muy muy
nervioso y dije a ver fernando tranquilo
espérate qué está pasando aquí este a
ver si estás nervioso sudando se están
palpitando rápido tu corazón y muy
fuerte pues es que no son los síntomas
de que te has enamorado
no se crean si hubiera sido tal vez una
mujer maravilla versión de cleopatra tal
vez sí pero bueno yo nunca llegué a
pensar que este tipo que aparte de la
policía y de los guardias está vestido
como civil entonces pues me torcí a un
literal por andar siendo lo que no debía
no lo hagan
dije chin le pedí disculpas le dije lo
siento
la persona estaba enojada obviamente y
me dijo este de dónde eres yo le dije
méxico se quedó en silencio un ratito y
me dice chicharito
la sonrisa de oreja a oreja
instantáneamente entonces le dije si
chicharito dijo yo soy fan de chicharito
sobre todo ahora que acaba de llegar al
real madrid en ese momento lo vengo
siguiendo desde que estaba en el
manchester united y desde que estaba en
chivas en méxico porque me encanta
méxico cuando me dijo eso dije ya vi la
luz al final del túnel y ya me salve
entonces para mí fue tan impresionante
que de pasar de ser sancionado por causa
de chicharito ya estábamos desviando un
poquito la plática y me dice qué es cómo
es posible que estás haciendo aquí en
egipto teniendo un país tan bonito por
conocer por visitar y me sacó un poco de
onda y tenía razón la persona porque
tenemos un montón de lugares de sitios y
cultura etcétera pero a veces preferimos
lamentablemente por la cuestión está del
malinchismo lo extranjero preferimos lo
ajeno antes que lo propio
lamentablemente o afortunadamente más
bien lo que no sabía el camarada este
tutankamón vamos a decirlo así de cariño
éste es que yo ya me había recorrido los
32 estados de la república había
prácticamente recorrido el país ya
conocía méxico
fue a partir de una anécdota en otro
lugar donde yo aprendí conocer lo propio
antes que lo que no te deja mucho
entonces desde mi punto de vista porque
en este caso es mejor conocer lo propio
antes que lo ajeno
más que sea mejor es que es más fácil y
se la pongo así por cuatro cosas de las
cuales dos salen rápido y con todo el
sentido común no van a coincidir conmigo
una la cuestión del tiempo cuando uno
tiene algo cerca dígame así nada más
tal cual este ejemplo que es más fácil
visitar un lugar que te queda a una hora
dos horas de donde vive o visitar un
lugar que está al otro lado del mundo
que te tardas no sé 15 horas en llegar
pues obviamente te es más fácil llegar a
visitar el lugar que te queda más cerca
y por ende como consecuencia la cuestión
económica el dinero uno cuando visita un
lugar más cercano pues te gastas menos
dinero en vez de andar viendo el otro
lado el mundo te gastas más económico
cuando visitan los lugares más cercanos
estas son las cosas fáciles no estoy
descubriendo el hilo negro todos lo
sabemos pero hay dos consecuencias que
uno obtiene al conocer primero lo propio
que lo antes que lo ajeno son dos cosas
que no están explícitas están implícitas
hay que rascarlo un poco hay que tratar
de comprender para asimilarlo uno es la
cultura
qué es la cultura la cultura es todo
aquello que nos conforma que nos hace
ser pero como tenemos para poder ser
tenemos que conocer entonces imagínense
ustedes que traen una mochilita esta
mochila es infinita no nunca la van a
llenar y hacemos chiquita que es de la
cultura le van a estar echando
y creencias ideologías costumbres usos y
sobre todo conocimiento tradiciones y
nunca van a llenar entonces todo esto se
están empapando ustedes de cultura
durante toda su vida y muy bonito
también toda la cuestión de la historia
a conocer tus orígenes conocer de dónde
vienes te permite saber en dónde estás
parado hoy en día entonces esto también
te lo da la cultura como consecuencia de
obtener de enpa parte de la cultura
tienes identidad otro concepto muy muy
importante pero que es la identidad para
ustedes qué es lo que nos identifica o
qué es lo que nos hace sentir realmente
mexicanos es acaso la comida obviamente
sí porque pues es algo que hemos probado
que es muy rico y que plantea este
patrimonio patrimonio de la humanidad la
gente su gente mexicana claro porque
convivimos con ellos a diario sabemos la
calidad de los mexicanos y su música
también claro que sí porque en cualquier
lugar que vamos lo que vamos a
presenciar también hace unos momentos
todo el folklore que tenemos y nos llena
de orgullo las tradiciones por supuesto
las vivimos año con año desde pequeños
hasta la fecha y lo que
a que voy con todo esto que no podemos
amar lo que no conocemos y en el sentido
en que como desde pequeños hemos estado
involucrado con nuestros con esas
características tenemos muy enraizado
tenemos muy ligado y vinculado todas
estas cuestiones y es la que son las que
nos dan identidad entonces cómo vemos la
cultura y la identidad son las que nos
forman las que nos hacen ser ahora en
este caso yo en mi recorrido por méxico
por 62 países lo viví en experiencia
propia me empapé de todo ello y pues
claro algo muy bonito primero de lo
local a lo nacional por así decirlo
primero conocí la ciudad donde nací y
luego conocí el pueblo donde crecí
después conocí el país al cual
pertenezco yo practicaba con mi camarada
tutankamón que es mi camarada vieron ya
pasamos ya somos amigos
y le practicaba cosas sobre méxico y el
muy emocionado me preguntaba cosas del
país entonces es muy bonito y es muy
fácil contar algo de cuestiones que tú
ya viviste desde mi punto de vista
cuando conoces lo que tienes y aquí
hablo de un punto de vista muy general
cuando conoces lo que tienes tú te
puedes convertir con toda seguridad en
el mejor embajador de lo que representas
entonces para mí era muy fácil
platicarles méxico porque ya lo conocía
yo siento mucho orgullo de ser mexicano
de ser regiomontano de haber crecido en
un municipio rural al norte del estado
de nuevo léon se llama villa aldama con
mucho orgullo también ciento del haber
me he propuesto conocer los 32 lados de
la república haberlo logrado y todo esto
es fruto del trabajo y el esfuerzo de
haber estudiado dos carreras y una
maestría aquí precisamente en la
universidad autónoma de nuevo león todos
estos logros los logré antes de los 30
años suena fácil tal vez pero no es así
vengo de un pueblo de 4000 habitantes
en padres divorciados y empecé desde
cero a veces es trabajar es darle duro
entonces si yo logre conocer primero lo
propio antes que lo ajeno porque no
podrían hacerlo también otras personas
que así lo desean a mi compadre
tutankamón les regale esto uno similar a
éste obviamente no se lo quite es un
sarape chiquito que usará y me
gusta llevar conmigo objetos cuando
viajo a otros lugares del lugar de donde
soy porque porque al dudar se los como
agradecimiento en lo que sea ellos de
algún modo tienen algo como un
recuerdito que para ellos es un simple
objeto puede simbolizar a todo un país y
no sólo eso también el hecho de tenerlo
consigo evoca la memoria de la persona
de quien se lo regaló entonces es bonito
que lleven con ustedes siempre algún
recuerdo
pero no solamente en recuerdos en
recuerdos los recuerdos en este caso es
lo que yo le estaba comentando a él lo
que yo le estaba dando de experiencia la
diferencia entre un recuerdo y un
recuerdo es grande el recuerdo es físico
es tangible lo puedes estar perder
en este caso el recuerdo es intangible y
se puede quedar por siempre al final de
cuentas y tú lo transmites como debe ser
es algo curioso pero me dedico a
documentar a recorrer documentar y
promover los pueblos mágicos de méxico
los patrimonios y sus sitios turísticos
más emblemáticos este cómo es posible
que alguien que
regreso de una facultad de ciencias
físico-matemáticas que es una facultad
de derecho que se dedicó ocho años a
sistemas a tecnologías de información
cómo es posible que alguien así se
dedique a promover la cultura y el
turismo
y les digo si se puede si se puede y por
qué o cómo prácticamente porque el hecho
de conocer primero lo propio antes que
lo ajeno me ayudó a mí entenderlo me
ayudó a conocerme a mí mismo
me encontré me ayudó a encontrar mi
verdadera vocación me gusta verlo de
esta manera todos somos de algún modo
como fósforos como algunos cerillos y
necesitamos de esa chispa para hacer
fuego en mi caso yo encontré mi chispa
viajando
y no es algo fácil no es algo que uno
busque es algo que uno encuentra las
personas que aquí están que me escuchan
que de algún modo se dedican a lo que
les gusta podrán coincidir en que ese
tipo de cosas no las está buscando uno
no simplemente las encuentra de repente
y las hace ser eso sí hay que ser muy
muy inteligente muy analítico en ver las
señales en ver los puntos que le ayuden
a uno a conectar todo esto para en
verdad hacer lo que te gusta para
dedicarte a tu pasión
hay una frase de walt disney que me
gusta mucho que dice pregúntate a ti
mismo si lo que estás haciendo hoy te
acerca a dónde quieres estar el día de
mañana yo cuando termine de recorrer
méxico de conocerlo dije bueno y ahora
qué sigue quiero conocer más todavía es
algo que no acaba no los algunos me
entenderán los que les gusta viajar
y dije ok renuncie a mi trabajo
pronuncie a mi familia renuncie a mi
novia renuncia a mis amigos y me fui de
aquí de méxico y en seis meses logre
conocer 32 países esto ya fue algo
brutal para mí sí ya de por sí me estaba
cambiando un poco el chip este viaje me
hizo cambiar todavía más regreso a
mexico y en mi caso digo hijo le volví a
trabajar en una oficina de godín es como
dicen y ya para mí no fue lo mismo ya el
hecho de estar encerrado una oficina
entre cuatro paredes no era lo mismo yo
sí quiero hacer algo más quiero quiero
portar quiero seguir haciendo lo que me
gusta pero a la vez ser útil a los demás
entonces yo dije aquí hace falta algo y
yo ya que había una necesidad de
demostrar lo histórico lo cultural lo
turístico lo natural lo gastronómico lo
artesanal lo religioso lo científico las
festividades los personajes célebres de
cada lugar de méxico a los que los que
visitaban y entonces fue cuando se me
ocurrió
crear conociendo pueblos mágicos y
conociendo patrimonios esto tiene tres
años y él conociendo patrimonios tiene
un poquito menos tiene un año en estos
proyectos estoy recorriendo como les
digo documentando y difundiendo lo que
hay en estos sitios de una manera amena
de una manera en que sobre todo trato de
resaltar que el protagonismo sea el
lugar y las personas que en este caso yo
me sienta útil haciendo ese tipo de
videodocumentales etcétera mi principal
es facebook la que utilizo más para
hacer tus vídeos y en este caso lo que
me interesa más es no solamente
entretener sino entretener con
conocimiento que sea algo útil si
quieres conocer en verdad la cultura de
un pueblo
lo más importante es involucrarte entre
su gente eso es lo que más te deja eso
es en verdad como la conoces
y así es como lo trato de hacer antes me
daba risa porque me preguntaban que
tenía que ver cuando estudié sistemas lo
que estudia derecho que tiene que ver
una cosa con otra y pues ahora me da más
risa porque no me dicen bueno que tiene
que haber sistemas y que tiene que haber
derecho y mediación que es la maestría
con turismo con cultura con historia y
pues que quieras o no todo se conecta al
final si sabes conectar los puntos es
algo muy bonito donde involucras a todas
las cuestiones y desde mi punto de vista
si lo sabes hacer bien yo por ejemplo lo
de derecho lo utilizo para las
cuestiones de marca registre el lo
legal todo lo de sistemas está en
proceso una aplicación y toda la
cuestión del mochilero pues imagínense
como no me ayudó hoy en día
la mediación lo trabajas con las
personas día a día entonces es algo muy
bonito
y finalmente terminó con tres cosas
probablemente se están preguntando qué
pasó con la historia de tutankamón
y pues les digo que cuando me quito la
cámara
yo estaba borra y borre mientras él veía
las imágenes entonces al borrarlas el
médico no eso no labores
yo le dije por qué no y me dijo guarda
la de recuerdo y precisamente es esta
foto que es un lugar donde daba la luz
una vez al año y precisamente la guardia
número 2
gracias chicharito no puedo olvidarlo y
número tres son tres preguntas para
ustedes conocen en verdad el lugar donde
nacieron conocen en verdad el lugar
donde crecieron conocen en verdad el
país al que pertenecen si me dicen que
no ok ya se llevan tareas ya saben cómo
ya saben empiezan de lo local a lo
nacional a lo internacional
de lo propio a lo grande de los chicos
lo grande
si me dicen que sí pues entonces yo los
felicito bravo estoy seguro que se
conocen bien ustedes mismos pero sobre
todo saben valorar lo propio antes que
lo ajeno y entonces ya nada más les
queda una cosa tienen ahora si tienen
todo el mundo por descubrir gracias
[Aplausos]